there's a story that came up about Mel
Gibson I kind of want to talk about this
the story was about I even retweeted it
is a story about the child trafficking
documentary that he's doing a four-part
documentary it was written by Newsweek
saying that he's doing this so uh uh is
this the Newsweek one yeah Ishmael
Gibson making okay
reports uh having merch claiming that
Mel Gibson is working on a four-part
docu service on covering the global
child sex trafficking Market involving
countries like Ukraine social media
influencers Matt Wallace tweeted it's
time to expose the truth while the
founder of the operation undergrounded
railroad Tim Ballard hinted at Gibson's
involvement in the docu series Gibson's
represented denied a rumors stating they
are inaccurate however high profile
political influencers have expressed
support uh with the former Arizona
governor nominee Kerry Lake stating Mel
Gibson's heart and soul are in the right
place Gibson's controversial pass
including racist anti-semitic and sexist
comments has fuel speculation however
fact Checkers have revealed that certain
quotes attributed to Gibson are false
and misleading so we don't know what's
going to happen whether he's going to
produce it or not if he does he would be
the right guy to do it and this Tim
Ballard guy has been involved in this
for quite he had some trouble I think
also a couple years ago but it would be
very I'm reading this book by Tommy
mottola yesterday about the story of
timing I couldn't put the book down and
you know there's a part where he was
trying to make a movie and this movie
was supposed to be him and uh Robert De
Niro and some big name guys that were
gonna do this okay and last minute
they're sitting there saying it's it's a
story about going up against pedophilia
and what was really taking place and
last minute it never got funded for the
movie to be made so movies like this
documentaries like this shows like this
there's a lot of people that want don't
want to do it because where are you
going to platform it where are you going
to put it up but if there's a guy that
could do it and pull it off it's
definitely Mel Gibson I put it on
Twitter I put it on Twitter yeah that's
why I was gonna happen yep and I think
musk would be okay with that so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]